l'accueil gaspard proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
france le fascisme est à nos portes mort
de clément méric militants d'extrême
gauche c'est scandaleux scandaleux
l'agresseur esteban d'origine espagnole
le chef des jeunesses nationalistes
révolutionnaires serge ayoub d'origine
libanaise clément d'origine bretonne et
en a marre de ce racisme anti celtes
et puis surenchérit sont un anti
capitaliste qui meurent au cours d'une
vente privée
[Rires]
échec scolaire
hollande va au japon alors pourquoi pas
et là bas qu'est ce qui fait il présente
ses condoléances aux chinois oui
madame 20e de françois hollande
assuré qu'à ce rythme là il ne lui reste
plus qu'à inventer et racines
chrétiennes de l'arabie saoudite
et lire des extraits de mein kampf à la
knesset est vraiment c mais bon on va
pas lui en vouloir c'est en train de
découvrir le monde se sait au japon il
trouve formidable et japonais en
allemagne y trouve génial ce que font
les allemands c'est l'extase permanente
et mais bon c'est le talon d'achille du
touriste débutants
quand tu voyages pour la première fois
même les bidonvilles de calcutta je
trouve ça exotiques
et si en plus tu as la chance d'être
traversés par la turista tu frôles la
transe mystique là c'était le
[Applaudissements]
international toujours cette affaire
d'écoutés aux états unis alors il paraît
que c'est un programme qui détecte les
messages avec les mots-clefs bombe et
attentats
prennent vraiment les terroristes pour
des concours
mais ce qui est vraiment inquiétant
c'est qu'il paraît qu'on a un centre de
surveillance en france aussi
si au stade ci sont aussi nuls j'ose pas
imaginer le niveau chez nous et le
logiciel de nous il doit ticket sur des
mots comme incivilités ou grand frère
international toujours bientôt des
élections en iran alors comme dans
toutes les grandes démocraties
il ya deux camps il ya les conservateurs
et les progressistes
alors voilà la modernité le mec de
gauche
on est rassuré si dans deux ans ils ont
pas le mariage pour tous ça va
grece fermeture de la télévision
publique je suis très inquiet du coup il
ya plus il ya plus de solution de
secours pour aliagas coincé
qu'est-ce qui fait si
pauvres grecs la télé grecque c'est
comme la double peine les gens ils ont
plus de boulot ils sont chez eux ils ont
plutôt
que c'est
ils vont être obligés de lire comme quoi
la seule vraie politique culturelle
c'est l'austérité
balance commerciale enfin une lueur
d'espoir dans les échanges entre la
france et le monde oui on la retrouvait
un vélib à bamako
c'est véridique
trocadéro suite aux émeutes onze
nouvelles arrestations alors 11 moi je
veux bien que la police fasse du zèle
mais de là à coffrer l'équipe du psg
[Musique]
médecine le premier greffé des deux
jambes a été amputé
qu'ajouter à cela enfin ajouté war ou à
retirer face et
argent guéant a touché dix mille euros
de prime par mois ouais c'est pas cher
payé quoi le mec qui doit travailler 24
heures par jour avec des flics
dans t'imagines quoi bouffer tous les
jours à la cantine avec derrick et
navarro
et bon transition avec un peu d'amour ça
dsk a été approché par les autorités du
sud soudan à dsk revient en afrique
qu'est ce qui ferait pas pour
reconquérir nafissatou
[Applaudissements]
les bonnes nouvelles
musiques qui tarissent du groupe queen
lutte pour la sauvegarde de 5000
blaireaux en angleterre
alors ça peut sembler pathétique mais
quand on pense que le guitariste de
johnny lui doit jouer devant eux
ah ouais nan moi johnny pas de pitié
pour les fans de johnny quand on johnny
hallyday qui a déclaré j'ai refusé les
beatles
dans une carrière refuser les beatles et
dire oui à zazie si c'est pas du flair
c'est un peu comme si tu vois arriver
steve jobs dans son bureau avec un
prototype d'iphone et suis une fan ans
qui va marcher c'est les hauts fourneaux
chansons toujours il ya deux bonnes
femmes actuellement qui se battent pour
l'héritage d'un défunt bon après la
fouine et booba jennyfer et france
sans que ça va se finir à coups de
louboutin dans une vente privée sephora
façon la musique c'est compliqué c'est
un art très très compliqué extraits
quand on l'a des cordes vocales on
chante quand on a une plume ont écrit
quand on a à l'oreille on compose et
quand on a rien tout ça fait du rap
passé
[Applaudissements]
à propos de musiques exotiques
il ya eu les y'a bon awards sa part oui
oui ça c'est le ciel et césar qui
récompense des personnalités pour des
phrases racistes donc le truc plutôt
sympa familial quand le truc en revanche
c'est toujours les mêmes que les
lauréats copé elisabeth lévy véronique
genest qu'est-ce qu'ils ont plus que moi
terminons sur une bonne nouvelle michael
youn est encore été cambriolé avec un
peu de chance pour le cinéma les voleurs
ont aussi dérobé les scénarios des
prochains films
alors est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu